all right hello everyone welcome to
another version 14.0 W language design
review um part of our intense season of
these things um this one is about
synthetic
geometry
so geometric solve values wait minut we
haven't we don't have a geometric solve
do
we no um there's a geometric solve
resource function the issue with uh
geometric solve is if you at least this
may not be quite as much of an issue now
as it was when I made the resource
function was if you're we're solving for
certain um say like area of some
abstracts polygon you at least used to
get a message if that was
if you know the whatever region should
fix it I mean I understand the left hand
side of the thing right um
it it does actually seem that uh that no
longer really issues quite as many
messages as I recall um so for the for
the resource function we just
inactivated all those heads which we
thought would be sort of awkward for
kernel function but I could go through
and check um
let's let's just look at this so this is
pretty cool actually what this is doing
so this says solve for a particular
angle for
example given this and there are
multiple
Solutions
um okay so this is basically you're
giving a set of constraints which are
like equations and you're saying Sol for
things why didn't we have this before
this is a really cool
idea we we had it as a resource function
but uh it wasn't quite powerful enough
to be a system function
yet okay so if I were to
say
um I see so this is asserting that those
make a triangle
right
so wait a minute why are you saying
instance one oh I see that's the
specific right so it the output is
dependent on yeah right so if you uh um
um yeah so instance one just takes the
numerical values for that scene instance
for scene one it's the abstract
scene but I don't understand because
these are determined in this case so
this is right right yes so they
are so let me have an underdetermined
thing so let the um you can scroll down
I have um uh so that's the next example
will be what you want or I want to do my
own so I just want to say triangle
ABC um you're need list around triangle
I don't think I should need it you
shouldn't insist on that I should just
be able to assert a triangle you should
make sure it doesn't need that
list yeah well what you hope to solve
for for that nothing nothing watch what
I'm going to
do okay there's my triangle now what I
want to say is
geometric solve
values
geometric um
and now I want to
say right so this
is uh so if you wanted to find the
abstract version you would do geometric
Sol values up right up that
scene and it will hopefully tell
me okay now I'm totally confused by what
that
um so uh so the it uses index for Point
coordinates we need to com we need the
coordinate of the obstruct
points
MH I mean
okay I was thinking it would just come
back and say you go in distance of ab
because doesn't have any way to say what
it
is no but it cannot say you gent
distance AB because you gent distance
want something with the right
form if what sorry
the if so if I now say here I see what
you mean right I mean it could just come
back and say just like solve would say
that in
um now here if I say
here something
like how do I say
um how do I say
equilateral
um you would uh
do uh for a triangle would be
a or sorry you geometric assertion
polygon uh string
equilateral
come on guys so close you got zero at
the end but why all the
crud um we
uh there'll be some a bug uh bug fix
time after the
freeze all right okay well glad I find
bugs in a few seconds it is overall more
optimized
towards concrete exact numeric q
and and approximate solusion not for
symbolic ones because this soon gets
quite out of hand I understand right but
I I think there should be a quiet there
somewhere in case something like that
happens
okay it's cool now why is this in one
level of braces not two levels of
braces uh that's for because it's a
single ton right well so solve values is
different from solve in that regard so
we're mimicking solve
values I had the same question
I
see but so if there were two possible
cases here how can I make two possible
cases
here um is easy way to generate a
geometric figure with there are two
possible
solutions
um I mean we had examples of that
whether didn't you have documentation or
not uh I for um yeah documentation
there's one in the documentation okay
or what geometric Sol values
yes basically again mimics what soft
values does so we just there was a
single list as Now list with two
elements uh it's I think the
Bottom by the way you shouldn't commit
things to this documentation that are
full screen like that it will cause
trouble oh well that's my bad I always
uh forget to uh okay um so scroll down
near the end I
think
[Music]
um uh
further basically all the way to the
bottom I think I know I'm just reading
these
ones I really like this this is really
useful I mean this is something where
you
know this is a very practical thing of
being able to solve for these things I
mean it's one thing to generate these
pictures which you know kind of uclid re
rerun but this is actually something
where you know given a practical you
know engineering type problem being able
to conveniently represent geometric
constraints and then solve them seems
really
useful okay right there we go so the no
no no the last one is that another the
under possible
issues
um so here is one where uh yeah I get
it
okay this is the case where why is that
a flat
list because it's uh if you have
multiple Solutions but you're only
solving for single variable and because
the second argument is it doesn't have a
list yes okay okay to be clear I'm not I
don't necessarily agree with that but
that is the
president
okay there are cases where we can't get
a real nice close form right so
especially here it's not an invariant of
the scene um
so um you know but wait I'm complaining
about the inactive
there right um
so why isn't it just pler angle I mean
if I just type in planer angle nothing
bad is going to happen it's just going
to sit there no I think something bad
used to happen um well then fix it now
because it isn't happening now and it
better not I will uh I will take away
the
inactivates um the only issue would be I
have to think if there's a
possibility where you
could somehow be solving for something
that would evaluate not issue a message
but actually evaluate well like if you
have ukian distance and you actually
list abstract
coordinates um then that will actually
evaluate and we would have to uh so what
I mean then it should evaluate I was
going say kind of people can def with
it I mean it doesn't have to say
symbolically UK in distance it can give
the X S Plus Y squ type thing thing oh
yeah yeah that's F number mind I was
thinking of GE of what geometric solve
would do that would be an issue for
geometric solve solve Val yeah you're
right you're right you're right which is
a good reason why geometric solve might
not be useful I mean there one of our
reasons why we have this function I mean
that was basically the
reason yeah well I think you're probably
right I
mean I think if you know what you're
solving for I
mean
the fact that
solve you know the fact that solve can
say x error whatever y error whatever is
useful in the way that solve is used
because you would be saying evaluate x^2
+ y cubed with these
values I think it's much less likely
that you're going to be doing well I
don't know not completely unlikely
you're going to be doing that here but
that pipeline is a little bit less
likely
here I the other
one
what's that I agree that it's much less
likely I mean right substituting into a
geometric scene is yeah it's not a
common thing I mean you know being able
to say because once we got this
geometric scene if we substitute planer
angle is 30° it's kind of a goofball
thing here
yep
exactly this is actually really quite
spectacular functionality I'm really
quite pleased I mean what
so I mean what happens if okay where are
its boundaries what what um where does
it start to break
down well
um so basically we complicated enough
scenes you're going to almost you you
you there's a good chance you're going
to end up with uh one of those
conditional
Expressions as your
output um if you know because there are
limitations for explicitly solving for
Stuff the boundary there are various
boundaries one one obvious one is as
long as you go straightforward forwards
meaning you have a construction uh
typically you never leave basically
nested Square Ro territory but if you
have say a Tessellation of a triangle
into smaller triangle you have a
circular Loop so you can get much higher
degree polinomial and we will not be
able to do them right now right yeah so
basically for the you know for the U for
the finding the exact
values um like it's decent with
quadratic
irrationals and if you're looking for an
angle a radian angle you know U rational
fractions of Pi but some exact values
are unlikely to be found the other
boundaries is if you have sufficiently
many points on a line that must come in
order because then you need inequalities
to represented and then you are in cat
territory with double exponential
complex
right so basically the fail sayfe for
everything is one of those conditional
Expressions where it's basically the
thing you're solving for and
then um bunch of equations yeah but
basically the equations that were used
by random inst that would have been used
by random instance to draw the scene um
which you know but so this is the case
for symbolic things uh for the numerical
case can you blast through and and when
you have specific numerical values for
things right so so if if you are um if
you are talking about running geometric
solve values on a fully specified
geometric scene so the one that actually
has the picture drawn then it's just a
straightforward um uh rule
replacement
um um
well you might have to compute something
depending on which quantity is asked for
but right well yeah well but yes you're
basically substituting the coordinates
into a formula and out pops an answer
yeah um right so that in general that is
uh what the heck is
this um so that's if you do random
instance you'll see the scene it's just
an example where you don't have step by
step instructions you have mutual
dependency
um wait there's I think there's a
geometric
[Music]
scene there's a P4 sitting alone in the
middle yeah there's a P3 there's some
commas and stuff there a multiplication
P3 times
style yeah I must have copied
wrong
and there's a
P2
is there there are a few
other
um in the neat examples on the geometric
scene ref page
yeah um this one might take a while I
think this one takes a while to evaluate
a one it's to limit what we can do yeah
this is
um this this could take a minute or two
to
evaluate okay well let's go on I mean
this is quite lovely yeah
I'm and also yeah send me this notebook
afterwards so I can uh find the uh that
reduce message leak um I thought I had
all of those holes
plugged I'm sorry what did you say I
said go send me this notebook uh no
somebody else will deal with that this
is not for
me who who's project managing here
Dorothy dthy will take care I
will okay so I should give up on this
probably yeah it'll
uh
um oh there we
go well that one was not a great
this is one where uh yeah sometimes
uh um that was UN inspiring yeah yeah I
would uh would dragging a point help or
no time probably not no I think this
that's too Hal yeah it was uh now it's
spinning right it's trying to uh it'll
eventually time out from trying to drag
the point can't you detect this
degenerous
we we do have some code for that does
try to detect it it
doesn't uh it doesn't detect everything
and sometimes it's hard to tell whether
it's actually a bad scene or whatever we
think is degeneracy is actually a facet
of the scene so basically we detect the
degeneracy then we see if we can do
better and if we
try but can't do better then we just
return what we originally had which um
yeah some of the more complicated
scenes U it's um you know sometimes you
know all understand why there isn't some
way of of keeping derivatives around so
that you can tell whether you're in a
stationary point or something and when
this isn't then you know it's kind of a
a random genery well right well we I
mean
we we for this instance we presume uh I
think the code wi detect that it's in a
degeneracy the issue
is
um trying to uh trying
to um find
uh uh find something that's not in the
that's not degenerate and we have a time
we have a time constraint on that and so
for something like this
where you know it's a long complication
no matter what the um that you know we
detected in genery then we try to find
something that's not degenerate but it's
it's almost assuredly going to time out
because this is a very difficult scene
to find yeah okay fine we made good
progress over the last two years with
Degen but for hard points we still s for
it fair enough okay let's look at this
what is this wait you just sent me
another thing I okay remember what's
happening is yeah this you're putting
equal in there because the the uni code
values were not pasting correctly okay
let's talk about this because we're
gonna run out of time what is this okay
so this is Jeremy Straton Smith uh made
this so I'll let
him present it Yep this is uh
essentially an interface to allow you to
build a geometric scene without having
to type the code uh so it's divvied up
into the figures and relation sections
figures so this is the beginning of our
effort to make an interactive way to
enter
geometric yes yeah but at the same time
a little bit orthogonal because this is
you have a pure text problem and you
want to convert the text problem as
convenient as possible into something
but not they drawing it but kind of more
formalizing
it and uh also remember to hit enter
yeah I was about to say
that yeah so if you want to spe you can
specify whatever points you'd
like um in the input
field these will take you to links for
the various documentation okay I I have
a couple of meta questions here first
question is has this been seen by either
ux or design
what you've done in a preliminary
fashion I think yes it's been a while it
was published originally as a resource
function so yeah it was a wfr for vain
yeah okay did they look at it
then I think somebody gave some initial
that's not good enough I mean okay
because I I can see tons of things here
which are not quite right I mean which
are you know design ux type things
independent of
functionality all right
so why is that plus not doing everything
because you have not specified fig The
Primitives that You' specified are not
properly obviously you've got to okay
let's talk about how this interface
basically I mean you know in a situation
like that um
the uh
um
uh you
know
um what am I trying to
say you know and something like that
it's obviously got to have a mouse over
that says you know you can't press this
yet because you haven't specified the
tech the grid underneath does say does
I'm aware of what the grid underneath
says I read it but I'm also channeling
what a typical user will do which is not
read
it yep
okay okay so let's let's start at the
top here
so okay first of all I wouldn't do it
like that I would a question mark thing
there I don't think you want to do
this um but that's an admission of
defeat to say you won't understand this
go read the documentation a nice little
question mark everybody knows what it is
but it's not like you're you know it's
not like one of those textbooks where it
says you're not expected to understand
this type thing that make sense
yep I mean keep in mind it is literally
the wfr which was made for the vain
audit
no I I understand I understand so what's
your point I mean your point is that
that I shouldn't be so critical or your
point is that what that some of the
classical well from language design
principles might not quite apply to this
audience okay but but in so far as we're
putting it in the system yes we're
expecting yes so as I understand this if
I start off here with
um
something like this and then I say
Constructor this does not yet
work okay but that will
work is that right IDE is the goal to
make this the goal okay basically it it
should in some sense behave similar like
molecule
door okay where you also can give a
molecule to start
with except it doesn't do the modal
dialogue thing
correct do people know that this
exists I think so I think uh at least
Jason dber promoted it pretty heavily at
various talks than
others pretty
nice how do why what does return
mean I think you get it in the
notebook and so you
do I keep on forgetting that things like
this
exist wow look at that
guy okay now the real question is
whether I can the geometric constraint
problem based on this in here how would
I go
from talking about your geometry stuff
here I mean how would I
go well you would right because our our
geometry is strictly planer geometry
well okay fair enough this isn't a
planer molecule sorry about that here's
a question could I go from this this
thing here to a graph is there an easy
way to do that or take one of these
other
things no there's no easy way to do
that and I don't know that that's even
makes sense I mean because what if you
have Circle through yeah fair enough
okay and what about the relationship
between these geometric proofs and find
equational proof type
proofs
I'm just trying to understand the
interoperability here uh Peter bareny
has been working on the appr that is
more discussion with respect to the
approval not the
law okay so this is a separate thing
okay what do you expect I
mean the first question is do we have
any hope of of nlu stuff even through an
llm being able to synthesize like if I
you know have we tried to get llms to
synthesize geometric scenes from
descriptive
text we've made some training sets for
them I'm not sure if uh what about just
trying them raw out of the
box I had no success with it you had no
success no only I think it has I think
it has seen too few
pairings okay so we have to F Tunis at
least with our
form here exactly but but I mean even if
you ask it certain questions could you
like like here as I'm as a human trying
to fill out this form you know you could
imagine interrogating it what Primitives
what you know what figures are there in
the
scene blah blah blah what relations are
there between these
things does that make any
sense probably
might be worth trying because I mean the
the challenge
here by the way it drives me crazy that
those are not in a grid but that's just
me
um okay so if I were to pick a different
thing here let's say a circle
through what happens I just hit return
just to make
it okay and then it's then it it it
um
generates you have to put in the points
right these are just
suggestions like you need to put in the
eight points for
triangle
yep
I took it both with with braces and
without it's
not
cool
so I don't think those are quite the
right words
there I mean I think you want to make it
clear this is a random instance
visualization yeah yeah the real problem
is and we knew is we cannot use
literally the wfr for basically this
purpose and this audience we have to use
different words yeah and I it is now set
up so we can we can modify it for this
however we want
really
okay
so what do you what do you want to ask
me here because I mean this needs a
bunch of ux and design
work
and I you
know I mean we can set up for example
okay let me let me start just giving you
a few random things given that you have
icons for these you should use them do
you understand what I'm saying here
yeah in the pull down okay and it just
helps people understand
what
um Primitives is a very complicated it's
a very weird word here I mean these are
the you discussed for a long time yes
what's that we discussed for a long time
what's the right
World objects
probably geometric objects geometric
figures I mean I do point out that
in I mean for what it's worth Primitives
is exactly what we call it everywhere
else in the documentation yeah well fair
enough but is does Circle through
actually count as a primitive because
that because if you Circle through
return a circle not because that
evaluates
yeah so about primitive
objects yeah it's not
bad I don't understand I mean here I
mean this vestigial piece of you know
heading is very very
confusing do you see what I'm
saying I do if you click the plus button
no I know then I'll get something yeah
but you shouldn't leave it V really when
there's nothing
there well this says select
figures what's figures oh that's figures
it probably has popped up on a different
window somewhere no no no no no no
select figures means this all these I
don't understand this here is all
figures right so view documentation
refers globally to the whole thing which
but it's on it's aligned with figures
which isn't
right yeah I'm I'm I'm brutal here I'm
sorry I just I've done this stuff for so
many years it's kind of like you got to
have that tucked in a corner so and then
the figures make it clear that that's
not documentation for the
figures um and clear all versus clear
relations no you know I wouldn't put the
clear there you know in other words
clear is not the primary action here
clear is an action after you you know
have all these things set you know Clear
goes somewhere different you don't want
to clear all when you have nothing there
see what I'm
saying yes there's nothing to clear if
there's nothing there
um we'll have more things popping in and
out of
existence that's okay so long as you
keep the thing I mean it was also
wiggling around as it as things uh came
in and out which isn't right either and
that's just a detail of implementation
now when it says name what is the point
there that's the name for
this yes in geometric scene there's that
you have the capability of naming I got
it I got it
um but you can't say name paren this
because this that is the name see what
I'm
saying there's no reason to say if if
you want to say this thing is called
triangle pqr then you want to put that
somewhere else here and its name because
that is the story of what you have here
is it is triangle
pqr do do you see what I'm saying and
that's the summary of this as well has
nothing to do with parenthesis and the
name because it suggests it is the
name do you get what I'm
saying I
do I told you I'm I'm totally brutal
I've just this is what I get for having
done this stuff for 40 years it's it's
like
um uh
trust me Stephen I've seen you in brutal
mode you're not in brutal
mode okay the
um okay but but look
here I think the name should be above or
to the side or something name underneath
is a very weird
construct a agreed it it will then shift
the elements around once you have no you
can't do that you can't do that you got
to you got to have some device where the
thing
[Music]
um also these large fonts don't make any
sense just don't make any sense in this
case look I see if you can get we we
should have a meeting with Noah and and
Jeremy Davis and and um uh this just
doesn't I mean it's you
know in general terms this is great but
let's get the details right yeah right
knew you would say all of
this you can just have the llm version
of me and it's like like forget the
meeting um go ahead can I make one
suggestion yeah I think there's just too
much going on in one interface here
maybe that just like just a triangle
thing can be one sort of slide and
multiple of uh you know well there's
definitely too much going on I'm not
sure that's the solution like think
about if there's like 10 or 20 of these
things right that that's going to be too
tall for your screen like is there going
to be a scroll bar okay the other
possibility on node is that all that's
here is the summary triangle pqr and
then what whatever is is the case not
all the choosers that the choosers go on
a modal popup like hit the plus button
like 10 times I get it I understand what
you're saying so I'm saying that the
thing you want to do is to
list the the actual geometric objects
here
um boom boom boom down the page right
with a plus button and when you say add
a new one when you click one and you
want to edit it it brings up a modal
yeah it opens up here you know thing
because depending on what it is you know
it's a circle it's a this it's a
triangle it's a whatever then you give
yourself a lot of freedom if it's you
know if you're putting in a a you know a
pentagon with all kinds of different
tentacles on it then you can use the
whole screen to you know you can use a
whole region to deal with I mean I'm not
sure you want it you know you can also
open it up in pain here rather than
having to pop it up it would be better
both for for the cloud and for this to
not have to do a popup but you see what
I'm saying so that so that what is
listed here all the this all the crud is
is is gone from here and it's literally
a list of the figures the relations boom
boom boom vertically it should just be a
oneline per thing like the name and type
or
something you can have a little
scrolling thing that a left you know a
fixed size you know box with with
allision at the end or scroll ability
that lists what properties it has
yeah does this make sense to
people yep I think the this we we can
sort out the
specifics yeah but it's you know this to
me okay so let's just talk about
workflow for a second for what a user of
this is going to do so the user is
reading a
description I don't know whether anybody
reads I mean you know does every version
of this actually come with a
diagram or does the user read a
description there's a fair number of
word problems in textbook that have no
diagrams
okay and probably there are also patents
that have no diagrams that just describe
and they incredibly obscure way the um
you know some geometrical thing
but
okay
um I'm just I'm still just kind of a
little bit you know as a practical
matter how do
people I mean well it's going to be much
better when we can draw stuff because
yeah and then what's the interaction
between this and drawing things are you
going to be able to flip between this
and a drawing interface
I think that I don't think we did deeply
think about this but might be a
possibility because it seems like
there's always a backup I mean whatever
you have in the drawing interface
there's always a version of it which is
this essentially textual form I mean
you've got really three forms here
you've got the actual linguist you know
language form computational language
form you've got
this essentially editable form of the
computational language form even though
this is not exactly horrifying to
edit but this is perhaps more convenient
to add it and then you've got the actual
visual
form so I'm saying
yeah um to
me I'd add there's also a textual form
put a wfr in
chat
oh
wow we use this we use this in the
geometric scene formatting for
conclusions and things and step
labels I think there's also been user
requests for this to make it into the
kernel
right yes there is at least one external
report for this but this is kind of read
only we don't expect to be to pass
this right this is kind of the inverse
of you know this takes symbolic and
produces natural mathematical language
rather than the question could we this
one
day no I don't think it's impossible
clear I mean this is not unpa we could
pause this into that
fragment you know in other words our
lesson from control equals is fragment
pausing is still useful
what I'm
saying yeah if I say for example okay
before I wanted you know I could say a
regular
pentagon um
with uh Center
o and side length two for
example okay I'd love to get something
which
is I I just want code out of
that what I'm
saying right that would be very
convenient and will you what happens if
you hit
enter well that wasn't so
bad I mean that's not
terrible but I mean it's also not quite
what you said I mean it I assume gave
you the correct polygon that you
wanted but it's not in the same form as
how you specified it you didn't say
anything about square roots and Things
No but I said it's side length
too yeah you'd like a symbolic
representation that actually just says
side length to somehow well only if I
can make or
whatever well if this is going to work
with the right but if this is going to
be with the geometric language we I know
it's also synthetic descriptions of that
but it's also got to work with Graphics
both of them so we whatever regular
polygon description we have here you
know sure better be renderable in
graphics so I mean what I'm thinking
here
is what we want then is four tabs
basically and this is similar to what we
have for the um question framework where
you have a visual way of entering it you
know a form like way of entering IT Tech
a computational language way of entering
it Etc right so you've got these
different tabs and you can go between
them and if you edit the computational
language and go back to another tab this
this kind of form type thing will change
and the visual thing will change but
it's a little bit a longer term goal
nothing think that can be quickly
achieved I
agree I'll be surprised this is doable
for 14 hour no no way right so okay hope
this yeah so I mean I I think what I'm
saying is not that unachievable I think
what we want to do is this and this form
are both
enterable okay and right now the visual
form and this textual form are are
viewable but not
enterable am I making
sense
but the organization is these are just
tabs you're looking at the same
thing in these different forms and you
can edit it in two out of four of the
forms right now and over time you might
be able to edit it in more forms does
that make
sense okay I need to go so I I think
conceptually yes we have to discuss and
think through some of the
details all right this going to be very
nice and you you've done most of the
heavy in here so now let's polish
it um I think for 14 let's basically
make improved visual version of this one
and then the other forms post 14 I I
don't think this is going to make sense
as a kernel thing in 14 unless you think
there's a strong reason for that I think
it should be
left the other issue for this in 14 is
there's the dynamic module issue which
is out of our hands and fine I I don't
think
yeah I just don't think it's going to
make it I don't think it's going to make
it at a quality level that we're
interested in I think this way of
accessing it is kind of janky you know I
think if if it works properly we need a
geometric drawer or some such other
thing or geometric you know I don't know
what you want but but this is not the
right way to access something like
this um I mean it's reminds me of
canvases and things as
well there's there's more work here this
is a nice thing but there's more work
okay do you solve values is great and
looks like that's a finished
thing
so okay what's that just said
okay all right yeah on noce point out
it' be nice to have name fields
automatically filled out with short
sensible names that's a good idea as
well all
right to be continued it's it's really
nice to see this geometry stuff coming
along all right see you guys soon
bye